[Music]
our smartphones are constantly
collecting data about us from the
language we use in our texts and social
media posts to what we like to watch and
listen to our data can alert us to
unhealthy habits lack of sleep too few
steps too much screen time now
some researchers want to use these data
to predict when someone might attempt
suicide for decades scientists have
tried to suss out the risk factors for
suicide they've identified some key
predictors but most of these describe a
person's long-term risk so the problem
with the known risk factors for suicide
and things like mental illness is that
they apply to a huge percentage of the
population and most of us are not at
immediate risk of suicide the other
issue is that they don't tend to change
very much from day to day
whereas suicidal tendencies can mental
health professionals can ask patients
about their suicidal thoughts and plans
directly but predicting a person's risk
still involves some guesswork therapists
can't monitor at risk people every
moment but maybe smartphones can one
research project called Maps mobile
assessment for the prediction of suicide
aims to turn research about suicidal
behavior into a smartphone app that can
predict spikes and risk the approach
could be especially effective for young
people whose social and emotional lives
are so wrapped up with our smartphones
suicide among teens is increasingly
common it's the second leading cause of
death among young people in the u.s. in
a 2017 CDC survey of nearly 15,000 high
school students across the United States
7.4 percent said they'd attempted
suicide in the last 12 months
in the map study teams consent to let an
app on their smartphones collect data
around the clock they're relying on
information from previous studies and
previous theories about suicide to tell
them where to look
by analyzing the language teens type
their tone of voice and their facial
expressions the researchers will look
for signs of psychological pain that
might increase their risk of suicide a
phone's activity tracking functions can
reveal disruptions in a person's sleep
habits such as insomnia which has been
associated with suicide in adolescents
finally maps will look for signs of
faltering social relationships rejection
and bullying
they'll track how frequently a person
reaches out to their online contacts how
diverse those contacts are and how often
the communication is reciprocated one
thing that clinicians have observed
about suicidal impulses is that their
ephemeral they tend to pass they
fluctuate and spike and then they go
away and so the idea with this app is
that if it could predict when you're in
trouble or when you're about to be in
trouble it could actually step in and it
could suggest a coping strategy for you
it could encourage you to reach out to
your therapist or if you want to set it
up this way it could also contact that
person directly
this research is still preliminary we
don't know yet whether the predictions
from phone data will be accurate but
tracing our digital footprints could
someday be a tool to guide people when
suicidal impulses are strong and
ultimately save lives
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you